بينما تتسارع الخطوات التركيه نحو التقارب
بعد نظام الاسد تخطل الولايات المتحده
خطوات الميدانيه مع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا مصادر كرديه
عسكريه كشفت للعربيه ان القوات الامريكيه
دفعت خلال الايام القليله الفائته بمزيد
من التعزيزات العسكريه واللوجستيه الى
مناطق عده في الحسكه والتي تتركز فيها
القواعد الامريكيه التعزيزات وصلت الى
قواعد التحالف في ارميلان شرقي القامشلي
وجنوب الحسكه اضافه للقاعده العسكريه في
تل بيدر شمال الحسكه والتعزيزات بحسب
المصادر الكرديه طبعا كانت نحو 40 شاحنه
محمله بمواد عسكريه ومعدات لوجسيه وشاحنات
مغلقه وصهاريج للوقود بالاضافه لعربات
عسكريه
[موسيقى]
بعد التصعيد التركي الاخير ضد الاكراد في
سوريا ارسل التحالف الدولي مزيدا من الدعم
العسكري الى قواعده العسكريه بالحسكه
وكثافه عملياته المشتركه مع قسد
سات عوده التحالف الى مدينه الرقه بعد
انسحابه منها قبل ثلاث سنوات وكشفت مصادر
كرديه ايضا عن نيه التحالف انشاء قاعده
عسكريه في مدينه الرقه تحديدا على الضفه
الشرقيه لنهر الفرات قبل ذلك كانت واشنطن
قد زودت المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا ولاول
مره مشاهدينا بصواريخ مضاده للطائرات من
طراز تاو المحموله على الكتف
[موسيقى]